wake up link from its mysterious opening
to its action-packed conclusion The
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild feels
like a revolution for Nintendo's revered
series it's both a return to the classic
feel of Zelda and a leap into uncharted
territory and it exceeds expectations on
both fronts you have to be cautious
creative and willing to go to great
lengths to secure valuable resources
Death Comes quickly and whether it's at
the hand of a formidable enemy or
because you charge it unprepared down a
treacherous path you're forced to
reconsider almost everything you've
learned from past Zelda games there's so
much to see to accomplish and to learn
that you never feel like you have
control over the world this is a great
thing where so many games front-load
excitement and wonder breath of the wild
sustains the thrill of unexpected
discoveries throughout you begin your
familiar quest to defeat Ganon and
rescue Princess Zelda with a little more
than a tree branch to defend yourself
from roaming goblins however it doesn't
take long to build up a diverse arsenal
nearly every enemy carries a weapon or a
shield and if you can beat them their
gear is yours for the taking this is
also a godsend given that every weapon
has finite durability therefore you will
blow through dozens if not hundreds of
weapons during your adventure which no
doubt feels strange at first but you
learn to move on there's no shortage of
new gear to discover them and though you
aren't able to utilize a consistent
stable of familiar tools you learn to
expect that for every weapon you've lost
there's something better coming just
down the road in practice the weapon you
wield is important but not necessarily
as important as how you control it
enemies and breath of the wild are
intelligent and utilized wildly
different tactics that force you to read
their movements and react accordingly
it's imperative that you parry or dodge
an attack at just the right time which
will trigger a moment of slow-motion
that allows you to unleash a flurry of
attacks against a vulnerable foe
[Music]
these moves are your last line of
defense when the going gets tough and
they require very precise timing to
execute given myriad enemies and weapons
you're up against mastery feels almost
unattainable even with substantial
practice however that also means you're
constantly learning in the face of
unforeseen challenges and there are
innumerable unexpected possibilities
that the game never teaches you about
you're never told for example that
raising an enemy's wooden weapon with a
fire arrow will set it ablaze thus
making the fight harder for you and you
may be shocked to learn that an enemy
will pick up any weapons you discard
during battle and use them against you
your power and wisdom grow as you
progress but you never feel totally
invincible which allows even late-game
exploration to feel tense challenging
and rewarding beyond weaponry link also
has access to magical skills known as
runes these include the ability to move
metallic objects with a magical tether
which can be used for among other tricks
dropping large iron boxes on
unsuspecting enemies
we can also freeze enemies and objects
in place for a limited amount of time
when an object is frozen it absorbs
energy rather than reacting immediately
to whatever force you exert upon it and
when time unfreezes all of that
collected force is released in an
instant
Bruns proved to be a wonderful source of
creativity and problem-solving both in
combat and when managing puzzles breath
up the wilds four main dungeons differ
from the norm in that you aren't focused
on finding keys to open doors instead
the goal is to manipulate the dungeon
itself to literally change its form in
order to access important areas it's a
wonderful break from tradition and you
still get a challenging boss battle to
look forward to at the end
gone are the oddly charming bosses from
Zelda's past they've been replaced with
dark and twisted fiends that are
powerful combatants like your fights
against normal enemies you have to move
and act deliberately or suffer the
consequences there are also dozens of
mini dungeons that test your mastery of
Link's combat and rune abilities
compared to roughing it in nature these
shrines provide brain teasers that are
an excellent respite and make great use
of the game's impressive physics system
figuring out what to do is only half the
battle the rest comes down to precise
execution therefore solving even simple
puzzles can feel immensely rewarding
somewhat surprisingly exploration often
proves far more challenging than combat
or puzzle-solving you may struggle due
to Lynx physical limitations and harsh
weather that hinders his progress
equipping metal weapons and armor will
turn link into a veritable lightning rod
during a storm and if you're climbing a
mountain when it starts to rain you
won't be able to climb more than a few
feet before losing your grip and sliding
back down you can fast travel between
shrines but to avoid long treks is to
really rob yourself of some of the best
moments of discovery in breadth of the
wild and the sense of satisfaction you
feel for overcoming its most foreboding
environments Hyrule is a beautiful world
to behold from the top of a mountain but
perching Lincoln High has other benefits
link obtains a hang glider early on in
the game which he then carries with him
at all times
your reward for scaling a mountain or
tower is the opportunity to soar through
the skies and cross large tracts of
lands with your glider and if you're
skilful you can even use your shield as
a veritable snow board to glide down
grassy hills and frozen slopes granted
Lincoln's surf down hills at any time as
long as his shield can handle the wear
and tear but it's especially gratifying
to drop on to a slope after flying over
a massive canyon or a dense forest and
coasts into a town in style
the few towns that exist in the new
Hyrule mimic the understated and rural
qualities seen in Studio Ghibli's
Princess Mononoke equally charming are
the hikers you meet on trails these
lonely yet upbeat adventurers offer
humorous quips and perhaps a side quest
with a quirky premise you spend so much
time fighting to survive all while under
the cloud of your impending fight with
the dark and powerful Ganon by contrast
your interactions with NPCs are
opportunities to slow down and help out
a friendly stranger in need now you have
a goal in mind breath of the wild is
just filled with delightful distractions
[Music]
if you've ever hiked deep into the
wilderness and found yourself awash in
wonderment and perhaps guilt for living
a life steeped in modern indulgences
breadth of the wilds reverence for the
natural world will strike a chord it's
the way the Rising Sun graces blades of
grass as you climb a steep hill it's the
flutter of a few well-timed piano notes
that dance in your ear and harmonize
with your own childlike amazement and
it's the unwavering delight and
excitement that each new discovery
brings it can come when you reveal a new
portion of the world map and find a
curious landmark but there's also an
endless stream of smaller discoveries to
find in the middle the fact that breadth
of the wild continues to surprise you
with newfound rules and possibilities
after dozens of hours is by far its most
valuable quality it's a game that allows
you to feel gradually more and more
empowered yet simultaneously manages to
retain a sense of challenge and mystery
which together creates a steady
consistent feeling of gratification
throughout the entire experience
[Music]
breath of the wild is a defining moment
for the Legend of Zelda series and the
most impressive game Nintendo has ever
created our light at must shine upon
Hyrule once again
[Music]
you